[Music]
pilot the [ __ ] Bombardier
[ __ ]
it's Monday whatever happened last week
happened last week there's a whole new
week a whole new set of rules and a
whole new set of [ __ ] waiting
to suck your dick WK & z the dutch
station i got some reefers today they're
gonna put you in a different [ __ ]
stratosphere you understand me
whatever you were thinking [ __ ] it it's
over it's Monday morning 8 o'clock in
the [ __ ] morning hey I love to wake
in Bakke [ __ ] I don't even let you wake
I'm already [ __ ] bacon I'm
saying
are you kidding me or what uncle Joey
with the grandpa from The Munsters
hairdo ready to swing dick take
prisoners like a nun but [ __ ] love
for you [ __ ] on a Monday
morning
so whatever negativity is in your heart
or whatever you're thinking about you
can't do [ __ ] those [ __ ] you're
gonna do it today you know why cuz
yong-chol Joey said so cuz they can't
stop you they can't stop me and I'm a
felon left back in the seventh grade I
got a GED I ain't [ __ ] dick they
can't stop me how the [ __ ] they're gonna
stop you you got a family you got a high
school diploma you sold cookies at the
[ __ ] school dance
you follow um same thing go out there
and get your [ __ ] dream get your
[ __ ] throat to fix and pick up the
[ __ ] floor you know I'm saying you're
gonna eat some [ __ ] meat today we got
some tremendous refuse as usual you know
me I'm with the [ __ ] on meaning
is over there at sunset are the best
weeds in town hey they're walking at
them lying over there you know I'm
saying if you want to [ __ ] and see the
want to see the devil you want to smoke
reefer you got to shoot over there they
still have two [ __ ] they still got
cheaper Jews they got [ __ ] everything
into the same lesson I was [ __ ] up to
the gills
we got a podcast night at 8:00 p.m.
don't miss it Thursday Friday Saturday
Salt Lake's and he sold that would Kate
Quigley if you don't know now your
[ __ ] no and the ninth tenth and
eleventh and Kansas City here I [ __ ]
come they're gonna lower the ticket
prices up to Thursday night for 24 hours
today so today if you paid more go get
your $3 back these [ __ ] besides
that let's smoke some [ __ ] I
don't burn out a great weekend I'm with
the recitals
I spent time my family had some spots at
the store if I saw you at the store
Saturday night the Tammy reading show
thank you called [ __ ] I also did the
main room listen I'm [ __ ] back my way
by Netflix the only one with the
specials coming out don't worry about
none just worry about today and how you
gonna make these [ __ ] sniff you
[ __ ] nut sack because that's all that
really matters at the end of the week is
how they sniff your nutsack not let me
to type of way and a psychological type
of way cuz you gotta look them in the
eye like [ __ ] you know they got these
actors out here don't like high contact
so as I find out on these [ __ ] little
prissy [ __ ] actors don't like that
contact
I stare them the [ __ ] down you
understand me I [ __ ] try to hypnotize
Anish I don't care how he ballin on
whatever house
I get out look at you Aikman bro how
many times you got went to court when I
was a kid you got I bought a [ __ ]
judge all the [ __ ] time just keep
eyeballing them when the judge makes eye
contact with you you that you can't take
your eyes off that [ __ ] let them
know your forgiveness but you ain't
[ __ ] around either you understand me
you gotta make eye contact that's why
you've never seen Uncle Joe with [ __ ]
sunglasses a go team that I hide nothing
the way I come is how I show up all the
[ __ ] coming at you direct
look at that huh tremendous this
[ __ ] halt or presidential and
this is something harvest okay so I'm
they got a Skywalker their sons a
terrible make your mother's [ __ ] sing
the national anthem and [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] kazoo you ever see a chick
playing a kazoo and I ran saw with the
national anthem you have no [ __ ] idea
it's a party of the [ __ ] ages they
don't even do that in the Philippines
not even in that [ __ ] cave with the
12 little [ __ ] apostles we'll talk
about that [ __ ] soon - anyway it's
Monday I might hit a crack jokes I'm
here to crack [ __ ] destiny I'm with
you you're with me and these
[ __ ] punk-ass [ __ ] wanna be
with us why cuz I'm nothing going on
they got nothing going on the walls are
closing it your walls are never closing
and you know why cuz you're writing your
goals you're going out to everyday look
at people in the eye and saying I'm here
[ __ ] what do you want to do
about it huh the [ __ ] you want to do
buddy yeah yeah I'm here 55 years old
me being the creepy [ __ ] that I
was because they had no balls and heart
you better look how [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ] Monday if you ever needed more
balls and more heart Monday's the
[ __ ] day Joey with the [ __ ]
air beat we'll put the quarter in you
who gave you all the [ __ ] line of
code no no I'm a little sad I'm gonna
work out this morning 9 o'clock tip-top
Magoo tremendous yesterday morning I got
up at 8 I went to the 40 and over aburto
crane [ __ ] class over there for 40
and over it was tremendous I'm a little
short I'm a little beat up people asked
me Joey what's your favorite jujitsu
move getting choked I get choked [ __ ]
eight times a day but I keep showing up
it's like calmly you keep showing up you
take beatings people throw tomatoes at
your [ __ ] you don't give a [ __ ] you go
home you calm your hair you brush your
teeth and you go back up and you're
thrown suck Mike they can call me shorty
I was born in 1940 [ __ ]
anyway why wait for 420 we need to do it
a [ __ ] 10 have to race right overall
they told us you know maintain that hey
wait till ah - you go girl Luna they
didn't get my mother is too old sorry
they didn't get my mother I'm off
running up or get Olivo you do your back
tire I'm sorry Nico Horner said it no um
no sorry Nico horn Araya yo so you call
my painter cowboy they took a toll on oh
sorry Nico Horner you said copy time
they both ate it but anyway a little
Spanish for the [ __ ] Spector rules
out there I gotta keep you alive - don't
worry about nothing I got you
beside that is Monday we got the podcast
tonight and tomorrow night I'll see you
in Utah they were home for two weeks and
then we'll see you [ __ ] out
there in Kansas City Thursday and
Saturday because Joe Rogan is taking
over Friday but you come after the rogue
and Shaun we're really cool like the
[ __ ] pound on fire at Kansas City is
never gonna be the [ __ ] same I got
three meals on the wet end in this case
one gets intercepted I got one knew what
edibles in one meal with methyl ethyl
halt and company you know exam anyway
let's celebrate Monday cuz is what we do
we celebrate Monday most people focus up
is your have a [ __ ] fruitcake we
celebrate Mondays we can't wait for
Monday cuz money Monday is money day
that's what we set up everybody all
these [ __ ] get set up yeah I'll see you
Tuesday yeah yeah you sharpen an
envelope collector you understand me
you know me if you're gonna be a Jew act
like I'm a [ __ ] Jew dressed up I got a
Cuban ready a sling dick with the heart
of a Guinea the balls of a [ __ ]
savage and a couple of [ __ ] I don't
even know but anyway it don't matter it
don't matter it don't matter you want to
find out what you are go to 23 m8 I'll
tell you you [ __ ] idiots you know who
the [ __ ] you are no you know what you
can't do
it's Monday get out there like I said
I'm with you you're with me and these
punk-ass [ __ ] they want to be with us
ain't [ __ ] because they can never be
[ __ ] real like that's real to the end
of the [ __ ] war you know I'm saying
I'll let you taste my spy everything's
[ __ ] real you might owe us no [ __ ]
real yeah that's why even Latinos I got
no hummus in me [ __ ] people we hummus
always have flies on their necks get the
[ __ ] away from me [ __ ] Oh anyway
I love you [ __ ] with all my
heart I just came on here and have to
bust your balls not gonna something
nobody just let you know which Monday
[ __ ] go out there let them know
who the [ __ ] you are you looking for a
job I can't find a job get out there
for reals get out there go look at
people will make eye contact stop
sending [ __ ] resumes and write they
ain't gonna get no way go down and let
them steal they are let me see what you
are look at their eyes talk to them let
them see that your toenails their your
[ __ ] fingernails are clipped then
your shoes a [ __ ] shoe polished he
can't sell a $10,000 boat with ten that
was sneaking something you understand me
go out there be a man let a more [ __ ]
suck your dick leave it alone if they
don't suck a dick today they're gonna
suck your dick in two weeks but they're
gonna suck you know why cuz you're a
[ __ ] animal with no clothes on anyway
I got things to doing people to say
let's [ __ ] make a few moves here but
listen I love you [ __ ] with all
my heart don't let nobody get over in
you today wait no I know help and I
don't let nobody get over on you today
today you're getting over on people it's
your [ __ ] world you control your
destiny and don't let your character
ruin your [ __ ] destiny grab your ball
salute the flag and tell them what a
sucking dick Elizabeth New Jersey in the
[ __ ] house Pennsauken New
Jersey in the [ __ ] house not
Bergen New Jersey in the [ __ ]
house Union City I love you yelling out
loud why eat cheese before equal I love
me is all you know I got you
[ __ ] from Lexington Kentucky the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] Birmingham Alabama
the [ __ ] Huntsville Alabama at the
Nashville to [ __ ] Niles Michigan to
[ __ ] Tampa Florida the [ __ ] now
what's the other one I love I love you
still might as well be in Texas so next
time you go to Bowman but Jesus Christ
joy we're deep here with the Nazis cuz
the time they still got a buncha Nazis
anyway Milwaukee you know I love you
I'll see you guys next year Dallas I
love all you [ __ ] but Salt Lake
City tell those Mormons to [ __ ] get
ready uncle Joey's coming Thursday Cates
[ __ ] parachuting with a bikini on and
it's all alone but the shot and Chicago
November I'll see you [ __ ] dead
I love you guys with all my [ __ ]
heart look at my eyes when I talk to you
look at my eyes when I talk look at me I
love you guys I hate to read these
[ __ ] regular two tulips look you see
anybody around me is anybody go I don't
give a [ __ ] I run like a long [ __ ]
wolf of debt anyway stay black have a
great day don't like nobody [ __ ] with
you today remember what's the church
model they're getting their mom might
ever be